Speaker 1: Today, I'm starting with stunning new
leaked emails, internal Fox News emails that show
that executives knew when we factcheck Trump's
election lies. It's bad for business. If you
are like the last remaining person on earth who
doubts whether Fox News is news or overt profit
driven propaganda, we can now put that uncertainty
to rest. Fox News CEO Suzanne Scott in a panic in
the aftermath of the 2020 election, saying We've
got to stop these fact checks. Telling the truth.
Fact checking Trump is really bad for business.
There are any number of write ups about this. CNN
has one article by Oliver Darcy and Marshall Cohen
from yesterday updated this actually from this
morning called Fox News CEO said correspondents
fact check of Trump's election lies was, quote,
bad for business. New emails show we're going
to look at the emails in a moment. The article
describes or characterizes Suzanne Scott as
sounding the alarm about the financial fallout
that they would suffer if they keep fact checking
Donald Trump's lies. Telling the truth isn't very
profitable. When the monster you have created over
the last 20, 30 years, 30 years doesn't actually
want the truth. They want to be spoon fed the lies
that their dear Orange leader is perpetuating.
Let's take a look at a couple of these emails in
this first one. This is Fox CEO Suzanne Scott,
responding to a segment in which Fox News's on air
talent Eric Shawn fact checked a Trump falsehood.
And Suzanne Scott, the CEO, writes. This has to
stop now. This is bad business. And there clearly
is a lack of understanding what is happening in
these shows. The audience is furious and we're
just feeding them material bad for business. She's
talking about the fact checks. The fact checks are
bad for business. Are we news where we prioritize
the truth or are we propaganda where we prioritize
whatever lie is most profitable? Well, we know
the answer. Here is another email. This from is
from Maria BARTIROMO, one of the greatest Trump
Brown posers on that network from November 7th,
where she says they need war, they need war. We
have to go to a full on war. They have used all
systems to defraud hammer or voting zinc, the EB
side in the vote total. Jeff It's crazy. Jared
says he doesn't want to hear about any conspiracy
theory. Everyone, us excluding me from meetings,
we have to file federal suits in every state
the campaign is not doing s. They want to file
lawsuits in a couple of places. That's not going
to solve the problem. This is Maria BARTIROMO.
Seemingly a true believer falling for all of
it. She writes, The country needs to survive.
We have to keep this president. No one thinks
anyway that people voted for Biden. He lost.
And we've seen text messages from Maria
and Steve Bannon before that show. They
seem to be true believers. They don't seem to
actually just be telling what they know to be
lies. Maria seems to genuinely think that
Trump won, and it's bonkers. Another email
Kevin McCarthy notes. Kevin McCarthy notes. This
is a pre-interview email about Kevin McCarthy, and
this is from Maria BARTIROMO, I guess, to
her team where she says, You believe Biden
won one fair. There are a few issues, but I don't
believe there is a mass cheat. Oh, wait a second.
So she doesn't believe it in another one. I've
not seen any proof so far of the ballot fraud.
Well, so maybe Maria BARTIROMO believes they
need to do whatever whatever lie they need
to tell to keep Trump, but doesn't actually
believe that there was the fraud that Trump
is alleging. And then Suzanne Scott on November
19th, 2020, saying, I can't keep defending these
reporters who don't understand our viewers. This
is like the epitome of she gets what's going on.
She says, I'm getting major incoming on her
editorializing at the top of Dana's show and her
dismissive tone and indifference to the audience.
She means not not just playing up the lies. We
need to manage this. I saw she just did a hit and.
CAVUTO I hope she didn't double down. I can't keep
defending these reporters who don't understand our
viewers and how to handle stories. The audience
feels like we crapped on and we have damaged
their trust and belief in us. Think about that.
Fact checking makes their audience not trust
them. She goes on to say, We lost 25,000
subscriptions from Fox Nation. We can fix this,
but we cannot smirk at our viewers any longer.
She is saying our audience doesn't want truth.
Our audience wants us to keep fueling the lies
that Trump actually won. And this is what Fox News
thinks of their audience. They know our audience
wants lies. They don't want facts. They don't want
truth. And it really distills the entire operation
of Fox News into its immoral and dishonest
essence. Stunning, stunning revelations in these
emails. Now we go back to the question that after
the Fox News text message leaks we asked after it
was leaked that Tucker was saying he hates Trump
passionately, is this going to make Fox's audience
turn on them? I don't think it will. And when we
spoke to Matt Gertz from Media Matters, he also
more or less seemed to say the people who need to
hear about this stuff won't ever know about it.
Or if they come across it, they'll dismiss the
reporting as fake news. They'll say, Oh, David,
those email screenshots are obviously doctored.
We can't believe that that that those aren't real.
No, no, no, no, no. Fox tells the truth. And the
truth is, Trump won. Now, Fox mostly knows that
they're lying and they know that the lies are the
best thing possible for business. This is where we
are today. It's tragic. It's sad. I don't know how
we deprogram these people. I've not found a way.
But we at least now have it in black and white
and highlighted in yellow, as you saw in those
emails. Fox knows they're lying and they know
the lies are what's most profitable for them.